- no one surprised lots of questions
because so much happened I guess they
were watching the last segment which
Republican candidate will emerge from
the crowd so if it's not going to be
drama I think that there are three
top-tier candidates you've got Walker
Rubio and Jeb they're consistently with
the exception of this last poll with
this Trump blip they're the three that
have been a top almost every poll and I
think that if you take a look say the
state of South Carolina in the 2012
primaries only about a third of voters
actually said they were very
conservative of Republican primary
voters in South Carolina so we talked
about said that they were very
conservative but people don't know what
those terms mean what liberals don't
know what liberal means either well the
fact so actually what's really
interesting is conservative among
Republicans has not never been like a
bad word in fact now you have to call
yourself conservative so it's not like
on the Democratic side you have a lot of
folks that are probably liberal but they
just call themselves moderate because
it's been kind of demonized as a term of
progressive now it's progressive but on
the right that's not the case
conservative is the label we love and so
the fact that you have only about a
third in South Carolina and a Republican
primary that say I'm very conservative I
think is really notable and I think it
means that you don't have to be a fire
breather you're opposed win this primary
yes okay I read recently that pollsters
are having a very hard time they are
because it's not like the old days when
everyone had a landline yep
and people just don't answer the cell
phone and when you have a cell phone of
course you can see who's calling when it
says pollster they don't answer
everybody please pick up before also a
big show they cited the British election
they got way off yeah Israeli election
they got way off and we may be entering
an age where we really don't know what
people think until they go to them it's
about to get even tougher this is
something this is is that a good thing
well the FCC actually has just handed
down a new rule the text isn't out yet
but it will make it illegal to use an
automatic dialing technology to call
even landline so even all of those like
all those robo polls are going to be
gone so a lot of the polling that we
have now
so lots of people really like that but
but I'll I have started to like online
polling which isn't perfect but it's
getting much much much better that's
going to be the thing that takes over so
I'm not leaping to much for the death of
the Robo pole but I think we've got to
figure out how to do new things cuz the
res we're gonna stop being able to study
vote alright mary katharine ham are both
political parties guilty of policing
free speech now here's the place i've
been with you i mean my closing thing
last week right was and I've said this
before about the Liberals had shutting
down free speech too much political
correctness I would say they're the
guilty or party would you care you would
perhaps I will surprise you by saying
yes both sides are Jody I think the
argument we make a book and a discussion
is that this kind of stuff is sort of
born on campus no right wing
organization and sort of proliferated
through the media and weaponized in
Washington is but gotten to a point
where it's like we can't just even see
things that are offended offensive to us
or deal with them and robot as adults I
think the Confederate flag issue is
interesting because I think it's right
and smart to take it down from
government endorsed areas but I do think
the impulse to eradicate this symbol
from American life in every way shape or
form which it feels like is what's going
on is an odd impulse I agree people
should have the right to have a
confederate flag in their house it's
that's yeah it's so unamerican you can
have a right to be an [ __ ] right
Apple got in trouble well they got a
little low back because they took all
schemes out of that Apple the iPhone App
Store if it had a confederate flag in at
all so a bunch of these like educational
games about the civil war were removed
and they say they're putting the
educational ones back but I mean that's
how far it got that if your game at all
had a Confederate flag in it it took it
out I think it a washout I think that
the point is of course before two weeks
ago whenever this a week ago when this
argument got hot it was politically
incorrect so to speak to even engage the
flag issue and it's to challenge
somebody the president stood today at a
eulogy and said that you were on the
side of what was wrong which was slavery
I mean that's one of the few times we've
heard a high-ranking politicians of that
ilk tell the truth about what
felt and people have to at least agree
with it on all sides I mean I think
that's progress okay should should joke
joke are is that right name I don't know
tsarnayev have been allowed to apologize
at his sentencing hearing you know what
let me ask another question about that
not that that's not a good one but he
got the death penalty but he may wind up
in solitary for his whole life
I think solitary is just way worse I
mean I would much rather Isis you know
cut my head off it's a it's a bad ten
minutes and then pretty bad as a
terrible person decapitating you if it
takes ten minutes well that but David
have you seen those videos no I don't
watch those videos me neither but I
haven't but that it's a slow it's not
it's not like in the movies we have yeah
you know but I'm saying as opposed to
sixty years you know they say that
people expect when they go through the
the solitary confinement area of a
prison to be quiet it's actually people
wailing because they're driving them
slowly out of their mind if that's not a
violation of cruel and unusual
punishment I don't know what it is I
mean and you know I'm someone who says
if you absolutely know somebody did it
it's okay to kill him me and this is a
case where we absolutely know he
admitted it I mean we have been a Monday
P did it so I think there's a couple
issues with solitary one is that
sometimes it can beat because the
prisoner cannot be in general general
population without endangering them that
is one of the reasons you get removed
from that population so we need to keep
that in mind but it should be used
extremely sparingly and the thing that
really bothers me is these stories about
Rikers Island where people are being
held awaiting trial and they're in
solitary for huge young men does a day
who killed himself after he was falsely
accused nothing ever proved and you know
that's how their confinement is cruel
and unusual punishment I mean I stand
against the death penalty as well but
that confined I mean it just it
literally the point is to drive somebody
crazy and there's a difference between
isolating somebody from the population
then putting them
how's Erica and it's we used to put very
it was it was for very few cases like so
many things mission creep we just kept
doing more and more of it they put Jesse
Jackson jr. remember went to jail for
like you know using government money to
buy Michael Jackson's old cape this guy
like yeah he wound up because he was
saying something we shouldn't have said
other whatever it was this guy shouldn't
be in solitary this is for Hannibal
Lecter right Jesse Jackson June there's
a lot of people in jail for ridiculous
things I mean they're pso2 to mandatory
sentencing I mean in in states where pot
is legal people are in jail selling pot
and I mean that's a terrible thing
there's a great documentary about that
called the house I live in and and that
is something that the president has
acted on in terms of giving people
clemency who've been in jail for a
really long time for things that are he
has enacted enough on that issue right
and his new Attorney General is horrible
on it I don't get that at all yes I I
you know as he goes down the lists gay
marriage and Cuba and immigration and
all the things in the second term he
said he's fearless now I'm hoping last
thing before he goes out the door is we
[ __ ] see ya wouldn't wanna be my
little bet it does disproportionately
affect a lot of brothers and sisters
this is very real yeah weed [ __ ] is
actually the text of the law very simple
and bitching weed is even better John
which was your favorite interview to
conduct for your book well that's gonna
consult a lot of questions after it like
my favorite old people if I would do you
don't mention uh well you know how Ramos
is in dead so you could say him yes and
then no one kills a live him complain
well Goris bull said the dead guy I'm
not dead he did I mean he was a great
guy and then a real influence in the
Houston he was also a she
yes and existentialist and he often said
to me you know life is kind of
ridiculous and so you just have to make
a choice do you want to be a good person
or a bad person and I choose to be a
good person and it was always as simple
as that to him good person and a great
filmmaker yeah I don't let his influence
is widely known ya know how big I mean
he was the Godfather of his back he was
the Judd Apatow of his era yeah I mean
he allows and everything yes that the
ghostbusters he did Ghostbusters
Groundhog Day animal hound Oh stripes
paddy shack I mean all of that and I
interviewed Jerry Seinfeld when I was 15
years old 15 and I you know I called his
his manager and said I was from a radio
station on Long Island but I didn't say
that I was in high school so I showed up
at his apartment with his giant boombox
and then he looked at me like oh geez
you're a child and and then he did this
great interview with me and then I
interviewed him again last year so I
interviewed him when I was 15 and again
when I was 46 and to ask him how did it
go how was your ride as a comedian and I
got you know two amazing Internet yeah
no that's great
did the terror attacks across three
continents on the same day mean we are
losing the war with Isis mmm well I have
good news
Trump has a plan tell you he's president
actually I have a quote it's not the
friend of God Nixon said the same thing
right
whatever Trump says I'm telling you
you're right other Republicans have said
it it's just their greatest hits I don't
mean to be flippant about it but the
literal Trump quote from the villa Riley
and your interview is no one is bigger
or better at the military then I am
he's bigger and better at everything I'm
telling you he also said nobody builds
walls like I'd yeah what wall is he ever
built whatever reason between him and me
we're trying to build a wall between his
golf course and Univision nouns you know
he truly is he's got a feud with
Univision okay so he makes his
announcement calls offhandedly because
he's freestyling right
he calls Mexicans rapists yeah any other
politician the next day we totally
walked that back I misspoke I didn't
know what I was doing but blah blah blah
it would appear with Latinos Trump is
like [ __ ] that and doubles down
Univision cancels his beauty pageant so
now he has a giant feud with Univision
don't never backs down yeah never says
he's sorry I'm telling you they love
this it's it doesn't it's like this
season of The Bachelor the Bob Guinea
it's really good yeah every time you say
bachelor Trump I think of Trump in a hot
tub you're welcome Michael Eric Dyson
what did you make of Obama's use of the
n-word on Marc Maron's podcast well I
think it was great I mean he's the only
president who used it in scare quotes as
opposed to using it seriously against
black people so I made good LBJ nexor in
the whole bunch of other presidents and
but look you know what's amazing you
know you know there's a civil war going
and speaking but Bill cause there's a
civil war going on black America and
part of it has to do with can you use
n-word who can use in word you use it in
rap music therefore you've made it
horrible for everybody else because
predictably our guy brother Ted you know
is it Nugent said that you know I can
use it now and I'm going to use it and
he started using it immediately I think
that's a horrible consequence for
everybody I'll change I mean that
doesn't sound like it exact no Jane I
you know what you think I'm crazy my
grandfather discovered Ted Nugent
discovered nobody here he produced Ted
Nugent in the Amboy Dukes huge is the
Donald Trump of Roger Oh Steve all right
thank you very much Thank You panel we
got to go